juste tu sais qu'il a fait tu as fait tu
as fait en terre inconnue vraiment pas
moi j'étais inconnu
ok si j'ai fait tarin kowt j'ai fait
rendez vous en terre inconnue et c'est
oui ils m'ont emmené les [ __ ] ou les
selles en lozère dans les cévennes dans
les cévennes mais saku sais où je suis
né ouais dans le gard j'ai fait rendez
vous en terre inconnue à 15 minutes de
chez moi
là c'est tout les l'émission passe en
mars et voilà toi mais c'est vrai alors
est il raconte nous de trois petits
trucs de l'émission le truc c'est que on
arrive le premier soit on arrive dans un
hymne dit on va dormir dans un truc
s'appelle le chalet de l'aig
avec frédéric sacré d'eric lopez déjà
chalet de l'aigle mois souffrent autant
toi je mets riches allez je pense à quoi
est appartiennent ouais je me dis c'est
kiffant on arrive dans le chalet de l'ex
a fait un mètre carré il fait tout noir
et on va pour dormir près de lopez il se
glisse dans son dans son duvet lui comme
une clé usb dans un macbook faut que tu
vois moi je mets juste un pied dans le
duvet par le duvet tu vois donc bref je
m'endors et là je te jure que c'est vrai
tu verras ses films et je m'endors et
j'entends frais de lopez dans son
sommeil qui diminue pas mal la soirée
ici reste du caramel non je te jure qu
il fait des rêves organiser c'est pas
des rêves comme toi ou ta mère elle
arrive avec une tête de girafes et des
brochettes le gars à côté il en train de
parler moi je suis dans mon duvet jeudi
non j'ai pas de calais pas de calais
parce que je me dis bon bah si de calcul
pas et il continue et moi je m'endors et
dans ma tête je suis dans le dur et je
me dis si j'ai envie de faire pipi les
trois heures du matin
il ya des sangliers des ours et des
loups garous d'or comment je fais
j'adore c'est pas grave l'huile encore m
étais de la fin que ce soir c'est le
rush final on est là j'ai envie de faire
pipi
celle là je me lève et je le dis je suis
en slip t-shirt en maître nageur je veux
pas révéler frais de lopez réveil le
cameraman qui est à côté de moi et je te
jure que c'est vrai la peur et tout
l'angoissent je rêvais le cameraman
jeudi j'ai envie de faire pipi donnez
moi la lumière tiennent le truc la
continental elle sait pas comment ça
s'appelle c'est ce que je lui dis ouais
je vais une faciale non
je vous dis je vais une faciale il dit
tout de suite non je veux dire c'est
quand même le reconnaît pas cette
pression je te jure je dis non non la
lumière et la [ __ ] ça me rassure de
suite
ils me donnent la progression s'est
filmé un tu verras indoor la frontale et
il me dit un truc qui me glace le sang
il me dit si tu sors peas et profitez en
pour dégager les rats qui sont cachés
dans le dans le fallait non moi je meurs
pour les rats non mais je sais je
préfère des alligators des anacondas n'a
même pas des rats et donc est donc comme
un café dont combats y avait des rares
dans le chalet attendons avant d'aller
faire pipi je le dis quand même j'ai
regardé rage veut pas sortir j'ai peur
wendy répit par la fenêtre et en petite
fenêtre dans le chalet mais la fenêtre
elle était encastrée
c'est tout ce que je te dise la fenêtre
elle a encastré sa fait que là il ya le
mur et la fenêtre elle enfonce anna et
j'essaye de mettre ma êtes comme ça
c'est cette impasse pas assez sa passe
pas du coup j'avais trade lopez lui
l'est où je rêvais grimacer cette passe
pas dans la fenêtre quand il se réveille
il nous donne une bouteille d'eau
signifie place dans la bouteille d'eau
on m'a circoncis mais respecte mon ami
je vais aller faire pipi m'ont porté
comme le chef du village d'astérix
frères et non c'est sûr ils vont
partager fait le pipi le plus rapide du
monde fait jure partie
il y avait des rats où tu as eu les abus
je les ai pas vus j'ai entendu des îles
on parlerait boyaval event à wade disait
ça
tuvalu